I've been hearing the sound everywhere
that blazing-fast hi-hat first have you
heard it it's all over so what is it and
how did it end up everywhere
these crazy facts hi-hat triplets they
are the hallmark of the trap sound a
sound that's been steadily working its
way from the Atlanta streets into the
mainstream for nearly two decades not
ray and I are gonna try to make a beat
inspired by the trap sound but first
where did it come from
today TI and gucci mane are both
claiming to be fathers of the genre and
no disrespect to the two major
innovators of trap music
but traps roots actually go back further
to the mid 90s that's when the term trap
really started showing up in hip-hop
lyrics the word was popularized in
Atlanta as slang for a place where drug
deals go down it's about a lifestyle
where you are
dealing drugs and it's a trap right that
you can't really get out of it or you go
to jail or something like that
references to the trap as a place
started appearing in music by many
Atlanta rappers for instance the 1995
song thought process by goodie but not
was a rap music it's the scene in at the
black community right trap music is one
that is unique and that is speaking to
some of the cultural and economic
disparities that exist in our society
today and so a lot of youth and relate
that brings us to the origins of the
trap sound and those roots extending
further back into the 80s with the
invention of an instrument that had a
massive impact on hip hop dance music
and pop music the Roland tr-808 when the
808 was released in 1980 it instantly
stood out we're not in a good way
instead of using pre-recorded samples of
actual drums to create sounds the 808
tried to mimic real drums which
synthesized electronically produced
beats imagine a robot describing what a
drum sounds like oh sweet sweet juicy
blue most producers in the early 1980s
did not like the strange Cindy sounds
that's when a stockpile of 808 invaded
neighborhood riff stores and soon young
creatives found a cheap way to
experiment with new sounds
eventually the 808 became standard gear
for any hopeful hip-hop producer in the
2015 documentary on the 808
Questlove even called it the rock guitar
of hip-hop here it is the Roland tr-808
the boom that you hear when you're in a
car then you hear that bass be like
that's typically the 808 boom in the 808
authentic source is from this actual
machine which is analog technology the
sounds in here every trap producer today
constantly uses this is how you dial up
every single individual sound that
you're going to use yeah go back to your
cowbell CB
[Music]
what makes this special is the iconic
legendary status of the instrument
itself now the technology is advanced to
the point where needle weight is
irrelevant because you can use any
software program and get absolutely
amazing ideas I'm still completely not
needed this is the essential seasoning
but is you're not using it in just any
occasion absolutely I dig it the 808 was
crucial to creating Krunk in Memphis and
bouncing warlin forerunners to the
tracks now you can hear the electronic
high hats on juvenile house 1998 now 400
Atlanta in the early two-thousands is
when trap really comes together soon the
trap Trinity ti Young Jeezy and Gucci
Mane but behind every big name there's
usually a producer playing a key role in
shaping their sound
you know without - without sorry red
like you wouldn't know who what CIA is
or Iguchi but a lot of people don't
recognize the names of the originators
of the trap sound like DJ Tom and
Shaunie
it wasn't until the next generation of
trap music that the producer started to
get recognition it was 2008 and 17 year
old beat maker Lex Luger was uploading
his beats to myspace where they caught
the attention of waka flocka flame lugar
ended up producing walker's hit single
hard in the pan
for long Lex Luger and other Atlanta
based producers like Metro boomin for
producing hits for a major hip hop
artists from all over like Snoop Dogg
Drake Kanye West so like I'm not a whole
lot of people are familiar with a
shudder red or DJ too but like Metro
boomin that's a household name you're
saying so how do you think producers at
rap gained as much fame as the rappers
that was revenue maybes how did it how
did that happen the tags the tags in the
rapper's and actually you know put
producers on you might recognize Metro
boomin its producer tag and songs like
Father stretch my hands part one by
Kanye like back in red and then we're
doing it they weren't doing the tank so
you didn't know who was making the piece
like shout them out you know Mike will
made it Gucci Mane's lady once the
rapper started showing their producers
up best producers we can't be soon
everyone wanted a piece of Atlanta strap
producers pop stars like Beyonce Rihanna
even Miley Cyrus all came knockin and
the atlantis town spread around the
world international producer started
using in everything from reggaeton to
k-pop
in 2017 rat and RMB surpassed rock as
the biggest genre in the US based on
album sales and streams and trap is
arguably raps most popular sub-genre
that means millions of Americans of
every shade right now are listening to
music that invokes the cultural legacy
and ongoing struggles of segregation
structural racism and urban violence you
think about somebody like a ti right he
talks about the consequences of what it
means to be a trapper and he uses the
music to kind of work through that just
in me how everything is all traps
everything and I'm like I mean eyes up
with my students so it's like you know
trap Yoga trapping paint trap karaoke
trap water and I'm like I mean I am a
trap purist I really need to get a shirt
it should basically mean sitting on the
porch so to speak and being like shaking
my fist like no this isn't but this is a
trap but I'm slowly but surely coming to
you know Crips with the fact that trap
music is now trapped aesthetics because
it does have that kind of distinct print
that can be used to update a remix other
genres that are already in place but I
also wish that folks would also you know
basically give receipts and credit where
credit is due
this just didn't come out of nowhere
track didn't just come out of nowhere
you know what I'm saying so now that we
know where trap music comes from let's
break down how we come up with the trap
sound
trap music has a wide range of tempos I
ranged from 110 BPM to about 140
I chose 126 BPM because it just felt
good when I think of trap music this is
about the tempo that I go to I started
with the 808 that heavy bass note that's
what we mean by 808 nowadays next I
added in that hallmark of sound the high
hats and then go at these alarmingly
fast rates of like 32nd note triplets or
16th note triplets
trying to play that on a live gig would
like be a nightmare that's part of the
reason why trap is so intoxicating
that's why it's so appealing on because
it's almost like you're hearing the
impossible being captured you know
saying next I added in the snare
the snare just like sits right in the
middle of the mix this right here pretty
much the basic bare bones of trap sound
anything else is like extra
sonar a created the sound base of a
bunch of sounds that she made they do
like a call-and-response kind of thing
I got all these waves working in like a
respond open space kind of thing you
sound like this is everything put
together nari and I mean collab on this
trap beat I should hop up right here
make it loud turn out loud if you can
[Music]
for some advice what would you suggest
we can do to make the beat or trap be
more like what we do to Mars man I
really appreciate you coming through
definitely absolutely sure let us know
what you think of our trap feet and make
your own download the sound of ink that
I created for LA from our description
and please subscribe
[Music]